actor cuba gooding jr has had some ups
and downs in both his professional and
personal life as with many oscar winners
the road toward continued success is
often paved with lots of twists and
turns here's why hollywood won't cast
cuba gooding jr anymore
to get the elephant out of the room the
most obvious reason cuba gooding jr
isn't being sought out for roles anymore
is that numerous women have accused him
of sexual misconduct it started in june
of 2019 when usa today reported that
gooding was being investigated for
allegedly groping a woman while drunk at
a bar in new york city gooding was later
arrested after turning himself in to the
nypd as usa today later confirmed he was
eventually released pending a further
trial in october of that same year the
new york times reported that gooding was
indicted on a separate sexual abuse
charge though details about the new
allegations weren't released they were
serious enough that they delayed the
trial for the june incident the same new
york times report also noted that
gooding denied all allegations against
him and that his lawyers had tried
unsuccessfully to get the original
charges dismissed some believe the
trouble began earlier than 2019 page six
reported that ever since gooding's
divorce from his high school sweetheart
sarah capfer in 2014 the actor has spent
his free time clubbing partying and
drinking heavily while displaying some
of the questionable behavior detailed in
the assault allegations i was in the
club the other night broke my ankle
what are you talking about well i
sprained it not long after the second
woman made charges against gooding page
six reported that three more women had
come forward to accuse the actor of
misconduct the report stated that these
new allegations dated back as far as
2008 and included instances of gooding
groping two of the women in similar ways
on separate occasions by the end of 2019
nbc news reported that the number of
women accusing gooding of misconduct had
grown to 22 which included an additional
7 women coming forward with detailed
stories that involved instances of
forced kissing and gooding giving
graphic depictions of sexual acts among
other inappropriate behaviors the coming
year proved to be even worse for gooding
as cnn reported the number of accusers
had grown to a staggering 30 women by
august 2020. gooding also officially got
charged with three counts of forcible
touching and three counts of sexual
abuse he still denies all wrongdoing as
of the time of the cnn report gooding's
defense was working to undermine the
credibility of the accusers by using
their past statements against them and
to question the procedural propriety of
the police investigation
in addition to the multiple criminal
accusations two women have filed civil
suits against gooding in august 2020 the
new york times reported that a lawsuit
was filed against the actor by a woman
accusing him of sexually assaulting her
twice in 2013. the lawsuit stated that
the woman referred to as jane doe met
gooding at a greenwich village
restaurant and the actor invited her to
have drinks with him at a hotel in soho
gooding eventually invited her to his
hotel room when the woman tried to leave
she said gooding attacked and raped her
this follows a different lawsuit that
was filed earlier in 2019 by one of the
many women who accused gooding of
groping according to page six bartender
natasha ashworth was working at a
nightclub when gooding approached her
after denying his advances gooding then
proceeded to grope her several times
unlike the 2020 suit the same page six
report noted the events that transpired
within the 2019 lawsuit happened a year
prior in june 2021 complex reported that
ashworth won her lawsuit in a default
judgment basically meaning that gooding
simply failed to respond to the lawsuit
at all
even before all the sexual misconduct
allegations against him were revealed
cuba gooding jr's career wasn't what it
used to be
[Music]
after the success of jerry maguire
gooding suffered this same career slump
that has plagued many actors after they
win an oscar despite starring in films
like the well-received as good as it
gets and the box office hit pearl harbor
gooding's post oscar resume is plagued
by a series of terrible comedies that
have landed him several golden raspberry
award nominations some of his more
questionable career decisions included
the eddie murphy misfire norbit the
poorly reviewed and little seen disney
comedy snow dogs and the much reviled
family sequel daddy day camp even with
films like the ridley scott crime drama
american gangster in between these
mistakes it was clear that the days of
critically acclaimed films like jerry
maguire were long past gooding gooding
has even acknowledged in an interview
with page six that he made several bad
decisions for his career including
revealing he turned down roles in
several acclaimed films like amistad ray
the last king of scotland and hotel
rwanda all of which went on to be
nominated for three academy awards when
asked why he made so many poor career
choices gooding denied that he was
motivated by money he said for me it was
always about protecting the sanctity of
that golden statue because i felt i
needed to show people that i can do more
i can do better
after several critical and commercial
failures gooding faded from the
limelight but still managed to get work
in the form of several direct-to-dvd
films in fact between the years of 2006
and 2013 gooding appeared in almost
nothing but direct to dvd pictures like
many movies that skipped the theater
these films mostly consisted of
forgettable action flicks and lackluster
family offerings from hard-boiled crime
films like wrong turn at tahoe which
also starred a far fallen harvey keitel
to animated numbers like 2007's the
laned before time 13 the wisdom of
friends after this series of debacles
gooding made the jump back to feature
films like the tuskegee airmen war film
red tails and the robert rodriguez
directed flick machete kills as well as
supporting roles in oscar-nominated
pictures such as selma in 2014 and lee
daniel's star-studded period piece the
butler 2013. it wasn't exactly a
comeback but it seemed like a promising
reprieve from all the dreck gooding also
made the jump back to television with
guest appearances and shows like the fox
hip-hop drama empire and the short-lived
abc drama forever as well as tv movies
like gifted hands where he played
neurosurgeon and presidential candidate
ben carson and then i read this
screenplay and saw that he had was
raised by a single mother who instilled
his faith in god and my mom was the
exact same way while the latter film
landed gooding a screen actors guild
nomination for outstanding performance
by a male actor in a mini series tv
movie none of these film or television
roles lit the entertainment world on
fire the same way gooding's past
projects did
many actors retreat from the spotlight
in order to focus on working behind the
camera something that gooding tried his
hand at in 2018 gooding's directorial
debut came in the form of bayou caviar
an action film that he also co-wrote in
this film goodings starred as rodney
jones a retired boxer who gets mixed up
with russian mobsters and is tasked with
gathering information for a blackmail
scheme against a real estate mogul the
film also starred famka janssen as a
photographer who aids jones on his quest
and the legendary richard dreyfuss as
the main mobster despite a strong
supporting cast the film was not well
received by critics and considering it
came out a year before the misconduct
allegations did it's not surprising that
he hasn't stepped back into the
director's chair
mega producer ryan murphy cast gooding
in the first season of american crime
story which covered the infamous o.j
simpson trial and accompanying media
circus gooding was cast as simpson the
disgraced former athlete and actor at
the center of the show playing simpson
was similar to the role that made
gooding famous the actor said i say this
is my second stab at rod tidwell from
jerry maguire because both of these
personalities are born from this thing
that happens with athletes one had a
positive outcome and this one had a
negative one perhaps that's why both
gooding's performance and the series
itself were critically acclaimed gooding
even scored an emmy nomination for his
performance oj
did you do it
no
gooding followed up this well-received
performance with another ryan murphy
project as a main cast member of the
sixth season of american horror story
subtitled roanoke gooding's starred
alongside sarah paulson as a married
couple terrorized by a group of killers
after moving to north carolina though
not as critically acclaimed as american
crime story roanoke still received
positive reviews both ryan murphy
projects brought gooding back into the
spotlight for a short time but they also
led to yet another controversial
incident during a 2017 event promoting
his american horror story season gooding
was caught lifting up sarah paulson's
skirt when she got up to greet actress
kathy bates at the event despite
backlash for his actions gooding
shrugged it off i see sarah paulson as
my sister
after both his runs on american horror
story and american crime story it seems
like gooding would be hot on the screen
market once again instead he made a
slightly unexpected move with a brief
stint on stage he'd already appeared on
broadway for 2013's well-received play
the trip to bountiful but had yet to
appear in a musical production in 2018
he was cast in the london west end
theater revival of chicago playing the
role of sleazy defense lawyer billy
flynn a turn on broadway can showcase an
actor's range while also earning them a
good living but gooding said he just
wanted to see if i could pull off a
musical that was the main reason reviews
for gooding's performance and for the
show overall were mixed while certain
outlets like the guardian gave
relatively positive remarks to both
gooding's performance in the show as a
whole other reviewers like london
theater were much more critical of the
lackluster production value and the
uninspired take on the long-running show
i played ice hockey 20 years i boxed
almost professionally
and nothing prepared me for singing and
dancing eight shows a week gooding's run
as billy flynn was short-lived he
concluded his run on september 1st of
that year before being replaced by brian
kemp though he returned to the role
twice for brief runs in both 2018 and
2019.
the current day problems that have
surrounded gooding have stalled his
career almost completely as of 2021 the
only notable film that gooding starred
in was the 2020 romantic drama film life
in a year which starred jaden smith and
cara delevingne as teenage lovers who
decide to live their lives to the
fullest when delevine's character
reveals that she has terminal cancer the
film held promise it also starred nia
long and rizza and was executive
produced by jaden's parents will and
jada pinkett smith but with negative
reviews limited streaming distribution
and another star accused of sexual
misconduct the movie was quickly
forgotten despite various court
appearances and no other film or
television projects on the horizon the
daily mail has reported the actor was
recently seen partying in los angeles
bar hopping and mingling with other
patrons
with another lawsuit pending and many
other allegations still under
investigation it's safe to say that
gooding won't be making another comeback
anytime soon with sexual misconduct
allegations being taken more seriously
after the rise of the metoo movement
most hollywood studios wouldn't dare
employ someone as controversial as cuba
gooding jr especially with a list of
accusers as long as his whether or not
gooding tries to mount a comeback either
by more direct to dvd films another
directing gig or some other form of
entertainment remains to be seen but
numerous pending court appearances will
most likely keep him busy for a while
if you or anyone you know has been a
victim of sexual assault help is
available visit the rape abuse and
incest national network website or
contact raine's national helpline at
1-800-656-hope 4673